from high energy performances
to motivational speeches stay
safe speak your mind and i might sound
like a broken record but wear a mask
it's a sign of respect thank you e.t is
taking a look at the most
memorable moments from the 2020 mtv
video music awards
tonight we are taking over the best city
in the world
are you ready before the show began host
kiki palmer started off the night by
dedicating the 2020 vmas
to the late chadwick bozeman an actor
whose talent and passion is a true
inspiration
to all the fans he touched and everyone
he encountered
he is a true hero not just on screen
but in everything he did his impact
lives forever
[Music]
the weekend got the fans at home fired
up with a sky-high performance
of one of his biggest hits blinding
lights before taking home the trophies
for best r
b and video of the year it's really hard
for me to celebrate right now
and enjoy this moment so i'm just going
to say
justice for jacob blake and justice for
brianna taylor thank you
lady gaga and ariana grande's reign on
me won
best collaboration and best song gaga
accepted the awards rocking masks that
were both
fashionable and following the current
cdc guidelines
all right i love you i feel like when we
were in the studio we turned our tears
that felt like endless rainfall into
diamonds
and i will treasure those diamonds with
you forever honey
[Music]
[Applause]
miley cyrus tore up the stage singing
her live
debut of midnight sky and she came in
like a wrecking ball
again i think it's for people they feel
like this is the place that they can be
the most expressive
and so i think that there's not a lot of
boundaries and so
the line that is very thin line you can
go over it
yeah it gets drawn farther and farther
away
every year dojikat sizzled on stage
before winning push artist of the year
and taylor swift snagged a moon man for
best direction for
the man guys this is amazing this is the
very first video that i've ever directed
on my own
and i just i'm so grateful for this
taking the vma stage for the very first
time debaby delivered a
powerful cgi performance with the
jabbawockeez dance crew
and bts kept the energy high with the
performance of their new single
dynamite
[Music]
and the army must be thrilled because
bts took home four awards including
best pop thank you maluma took home the
award for best
latin i feel proud of my culture i feel
very proud of midland
right after his high energy performance
at the skyline drive-in in brooklyn
but it was a huge night for lady gaga
not only did she win artist of the year
the 34 year old songstress received the
first ever mtv tricon award
i want to share this award with
everybody at home tonight
[Applause]
everybody at home that is their own form
of a tri-con
i wish for you to think right now of
three things
that define who you are and take a
moment
to reward yourself for your bravery